Hey, Vsauce.
Michael here.
And today we've got DONG, things you can do
online now, guys.
Let's begin with a recommendation from @catchfoot,
supercut.org.
It's a reservoir of video collections.
For instance, every Steve Buscemi death on
camera.
Four minutes of people giving out 555 numbers
in movies, or a minute-and-a-half of vloggers
apologising for not realising videos lately.
For a "in real life" supercut, check out Winter,
he's on a mission to visit every single Starbucks
in the world.
His site is a great destination for photos
of Starbucks, like lots of them.
MegaRandompeoplez recommended Depict1, a great
game where the narrator lies to you and you
have to disobey in order to move forward,
never knowing what to believe.
ConfusedAshleyK has even more control in Level
Editor.
You have only a short amount of time to both
build the level and complete it.
Keep built things safe in Epic Rail, where
you have to switch rail paths to send trains
in the right direction while keeping them
from colliding.
Now, as a Tower Defence lover I have to agree
with Blackmamba329, Balloon Tower Defence
is quite fun.
Saintsage777 reminded me of rainymood.com,
a relaxing site of continuous rain noise.
I was always told to play it while listening
to the Widdler's Day and Night Dubstep remix
for the ultimate effect.
Make your own dubstep remixes with Wub Machine.
The site does its best to remix whatever song
you drag in.
Make the beat yourself like MatthewTS22 with
this from RonWinter, the keyboard controls
all the fun sounds.
Incredibox comes via Vegemitosis and it's
a brilliant a capella song you can control
the layers of.
Drag in new voices, new beat boxing, new back
up singers, etc., etc.
CreatureFeatureRIz showed off Seaquence, a
site where you also control the music, but
by building little sea creatures that make
noise based on their shapes.
Have them live together and make music together.
Now, I love ambigrams - figures that are one
thing from angle and another from a different
angle.
This website makes them for you.
For instance, my first and last name makes
this one.
See, at first it says Michael, but upside
down it says Stevens.
If you still have free time left, check out
TehN1ppe.
He loops simple images and sounds over and
over and over again, but through wizardry
of compression and patience he makes them
all ten hours long.
Want more?
Zommyo pointed me to the longest video on
YouTube.
It's compressed beyond all recognition but
clocks in at 596 hours long.
Not long enough?
Check out the longest list of the longest
stuff at the longest domain name at long last.com.
The site catalogues the longest of almost
everything.
The longest book, longest popsicle, longest
spacewalk, longest distance walked backwards,
longest zucchini and on and on and on.
And on Twitter last week I showed off one
of the YouTube comments with the most thumb-ups
ever, so follow us to stay up to date.
And, if you're not already subscribed to Vsauce2,
you're missing out on half of Vsauce.
If you subscribe to Vsauce2, you get mind
blowing technology, weird people fact, more
leanbacks.
It's literally twice the sauce.
So pour some all over.
And as always,
thanks for watching.